the 2020 sakharov prize for freedom of
thought will go to the democratic
opposition in belarus
president sacely announced the winner on
the 75th day of peaceful protests in the
country
the common agricultural policy provides
support for up to seven
million farms across the european union
the current rules will soon expire
meps want to make farm policy more
resilient sustainable and flexible to
cope with future crises
parliament wants to boost innovation in
artificial intelligence
mep's made recommendations for future ai
legislation
focusing on three main issues ethics
liability and intellectual property
rights
[Music]
since 1990 1.3 million square kilometers
of forest have been lost globally
an area larger than south africa meps
called for binding measures to prohibit
products that contribute to
deforestation from being placed on the
eu market
up to 32 percent of pupils in the eu did
not have access to education during
covet 19 lockdowns
meps want to close the digital
infrastructure gap and ensure that
everyone is able to learn
even in a crisis